look number two we'll just kind of focus
more on life purpose think kind of like
what the dead would do differently if
they can do it over Hollywood medium
Tyler Henry on the regrets the deceased
have after they pass the way that kind
of comes through is they they're able to
understand that if they had a second
shot at it they could have done things
differently but they also accept when
they transition how they dealt with
things helping to end his life
what is the biggest redo wish that
people they wish they would have worked
less they wish they would have been more
present they wish they would have
communicated more yeah those are kind of
big things and get this the 22 year old
has a redo wish of his own a celebrity
reading from season one boy George
really I think doing it a second round
it might be a good opportunity for him
to be a little bit more open I think in
our first meeting he definitely got some
validations but he left that experience
and acknowledged that maybe if you were
to do it a second time he'd come with a
makeup off and that I think was very
telling because he I think might have
been a little uncomfortable going in
certain areas personal sense do you have
a dream celebrity that you would love to
read alive dead I do Tonya Harding
actually I think she's fascinating man
she had a very tumultuous upbringing and
I think that there's a lot of healing to
be had there and I admire her for what
she's gone through and how she's been
resilient through it so I think that's
someone that could really benefit from
it